Well, good morning again, church.
Welcome to Henderson Hills.
My name is John Lead teaching pastor here.
It's always a joy to gather together like this.
Um, as you can hear, probably most all
of us in this room have been hit over the last couple
weeks with something, right?
Uh, so I am on the back end of it.
So let's just pray that this thing keeps
going the whole time.
We'll see. Uh,
but we're continuing our series today called He Shall Reign.
It's in one Samuel where we're looking at
what it re really means to have God as our king,
what that truly means.
And as we get into it today, I wanna begin
by telling you about what were the two hardest weeks
of every year in college for me.
Uh, they're known as training camp
or two adays often is what it was referred to back then.
They don't do that so much anymore, but it's what it was.
And it was when the football team would come back
after the summer of workouts and we'd gather together
and we'd strap the pads on.
We'd really begin to work at what we were looking forward
to for the season.
And every day, somehow it seemed
to be a hundred degrees all day.
There was zero clouds in the sky.
I don't know how that works out every
August, but that's how it was.
And we ate, drank, and slept
football every single day for those couple weeks.
And it was meant to prepare us for the grind
of the season, right?
But there was a dual purpose to it
because it was also meant to weed out those
who couldn't endure it.
See, it revealed a lot about who a person really is.
When you get into that moment,
are you going to brave through it?
Are you going to stay steadfast?
Are you going to do the right thing every time,
even when it's hard?
Or were you gonna bail? Were
you gonna take the easy way out?
Were you gonna look for shortcuts?
But when you think about it, isn't that true
of any difficult moment in our lives?
You don't have to be in a hundred degree heat
for three hours getting screamed at by a coach
to have this situation revealed.
It's when you get that diagnosis
or when your boss comes down hard on you, or
whenever you're tempted again by that same thing,
you just can't seem to get over
or when you're getting shunned
for being a believer at school or
whenever you are facing financial difficulties.
Any of those moments in life.
Have you ever thought that God could be using those
training camps for your good,
to test you, to reveal your faith
to others, but also to you?
God did that for David here in one Samuel 21.
But the question before us today,
before we turn there, the question for us is
how are we gonna respond when we face the
hardships of trading camp?
And we'll look for it today in God's word
as we turn together to one Samuel Chapter
21, 1 Samuel 21.
If you're not there already, David was on the run
from King Saul.
He, he was a man jealous of God's anointing
and he, God's presence with David.
And now David knew for sure
that Saul was trying to kill him.
And so he's on the run.
And in this chapter we're gonna see three scenes.
They all fit together, but they also all set
us up for something later.
It's what the narrator does a great job
of preparing us for something.
But this, this works.
And, and what we'll see here is watching God show more
of himself to us through these scenes
with David in his life.
I'm gonna read the whole section starting in verse one
of one, Samuel 21.
Then David came to knob to Alek, the priest.
Alek came to him,
meet David Trembling said to him, why are you alone?
No one with you. David said to Alek the priest,
the kings charged me with a matter
and said to me, let no one know anything
of the matter about which I send you
with which I've charged you.
I've made an appointment with the young men for such
and such a place, meaning my men are waiting for me now then
what do you have on hand?
Gimme five loaves of bread or whatever is here.
And the priest answered, David,
I have no common bread on hand,
but there's holy bread if the young men
have kept themselves from women.
And David answered the priest, truly,
women have been kept from us as always,
when I go on an expedition, meaning they're, they're clean,
uh, ceremonially, the vessels
of the young men are holy even
when it's an ordinary journey.
How much more today will their vessels be holy?
So the priest gave him the holy bread
for there was no bread there,
but the bread of the presence in the tabernacle,
which is removed from
before the Lord to be replaced
by hot bread on the taken away.
Now, a certain man of the servants of Saul was there
that day, detained before the Lord.
His name was Dogue, the mite, the chief of Saul's herdsman.
It's kind of inserted there.
We'll come back to that actually in next Sunday's sermon.
But then David said to Alek, then, have you not here a spear
or a sword at hand?
I brought neither my sword nor my weapons with me.
'cause the king's business required haste.
And the priest said, the sword of Goliath,
the Philistine whom you struck down in the valley of Elah.
Behold it's wrapped here in a cloth behind the ifad.
If you'll take that, take it. There's none but that here.
And David said, there's none like it. Give it to me.
And David Rose and fled that day from Saul
and went to Aish, the king of gaff.
And the servants of Aish said to him,
is this not David the king of the land?
Did they not sing to one another of him? And dances?
Remember this, Saul has struck down his thousands.
David is 10,000.
And David took these words to heart
and was much afraid of Aish the king of God.
So he changed his behavior
before them pretended to be insane in their hands,
made marks on the doors of the gate,
let his spittle run down his beard.
Then Aker said to his servants, behold,
you see this man is mad.
Why have you brought him to me? Do I lack mad men?
You've brought this fellow to behave
as a mad men in my presence,
shall this fellow come into my house?
So David departed from there, escaped to the cave
of a doula when his brothers
and all his father's house heard it.
They went down there to him, everyone who was in distress,
everyone who was in debt, everyone who was bitter in
soul gathered to him.
He became commander over them.
And there were about 400 men with them.
David went from there to MPA of Moab
and he said to the king of Moab, please let my father,
my mother stay with you till I know what God will do for me.
He left them with the king of Moab.
And they stayed with them all the time
that David was in the stronghold.
And then the prophet Gad said to David,
do not remain in the stronghold.
Depart, go into the land of Judah.
So David departed, went into the forest of Herath.
God, we pray as we look at this text that is
scenes of David's life, may it not just be a narrative
to us, but God, we ask you by your spirit
to change our hearts and to change our lives.
Only you can do that. Strengthen us. Sustain us.
Challenge us. Don't let us walk out of here being hearers
and not doers of your word.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Now, one of the parts I love
of the Bible is that it's so honest.
See, it never sugarcoats anything.
It doesn't shy away from telling you both the good
and the bad about someone's life.
See, David is often the hero in our minds, right?
We look at David and Goliath, all the things David did,
he's a hero to us.
But here in this scene, he's still in training camp mode.
He's needing to grow more fully into the man
after God's own heart that he actually was.
So what did God do? God put David into situations
to test his dependence.
God put David in situations to test his dependence.
Like those August days when the coach would take someone
farther than they really needed to go, what
that would do is it would prove to that player
that they could do it, that they could actually make it.
God's doing that in a way here with David.
And watch how David responded.
Well, initially he stretched the truth.
David's response to this training camp was
that he stretched the truth initially.
So remember what happened here? He, he shows up
to this priest and he shared a story about how the king,
we'll get back to that in a second,
sent him on this super secret mission
that he had to come alone.
He had to come in a, in a rush. All of that.
Was that the truth? We don't actually know.
It doesn't seem like it's a full on lie,
because later in Mark two actually
Jesus referenced this scene.
He wasn't critical about it,
but it certainly had some measure of
not fully true, right?
Like he, he, he was maybe trying to protect the priest
that the priest didn't get accused
of being a conspirator with him.
Maybe that's what he was trying to do.
But it, it, whatever it was,
it was certainly a stretch, right?
'cause some people would say, well, he was referring to God
as the king who sent him on this mission, okay?
Even if he was like,
that's still at the very least stretching the truth
a little bit so he could have food and weaponry.
That's really what he was after.
Remember the same man who a couple chapters earlier
to Goliath said, no, God doesn't save by sword or spear.
And now he's like, gimme a sword. I need a sword, right?
So he's stretching the truth a little bit
and maybe out of fear,
even in the next scene, we see it as well.
David took off into Philistine country.
He was captured, how'd he get outta that?
Because the, the Philistines remembered David naturally,
they knew he was the king.
They knew the songs. People sang about him.
They knew David was the one. How'd he get out of it?
Remember verse 13 of chapter 21, he changed his behavior
before them and pretended to be insane in their hands
and made marks on the doors of the gate
and let his spit run down his beard.
Like, isn't that crazy?
I couldn't help but think of this guy
whenever I read that verse, right?
Well, sad, right?
I couldn't, I can't yell that right now like he could.
But, uh, that, that's what I thought
of just this insane figure
that he was trying to portray to them.
But, but remember, David's not crazy, right? He was acting.
So was was he just being resourceful like a good soldier,
getting out of his sticky situation?
Was that what he was doing? At the very least,
he's stretching the truth.
And listen, those things might seem like minor, but,
but they lead actually to very severe consequences later.
They lead to severe consequences
even as quickly as next week in the rest of chapter 22.
What David did when he went to Knob
and he talked to the priest
and he did all the things that he did, it ended up
where 85 priests get killed at the hands of Saul.
And just as an aside, sin always has consequences.
At the very least, David didn't trust God fully.
And so sin always has consequences.
Whether the pain shows up immediately
or not, sin will always bring about Galatians six says,
you will always reap what you sow
even if it's not immediate.
But here's what we also see in this training camp scene.
We see David's growth.
He grows like just at the, just like at the end
of those weeks in August, we would be more fit, stronger,
more capable to enter into the season.
Like that's the way it works.
You go through training camp, you make it through
and you are stronger on the other side of it,
David was growing
and that's what we see at chapter 22, beginning.
First, the first five verses that David finally came
around to trust the Lord.
He finally did trust the Lord.
In the end, I wanna read verses three
through five again of chapter 22.
Watch this. He'd gone through those scenes.
He'd been exiled now into this cave.
And David went from there to Mspa of Moab.
He said to the king of Moab, please let my father
and my mother stay with you till I know what
God will do for me.
And he left them with the king of Moab.
They stayed with him all the time.
David was in the stronghold.
And then the prophet Gad said to David,
do not remain in the stronghold.
Depart, go into the land of Judah.
So David departed went into the forest
of hath, right?
So, so did you notice something different here?
For the first time in any of these scenes,
God's name is mentioned, God's involved
in the process of David walking
out this life, the first two scenes.
What did he trust? His own craftiness,
his own skill, his own wisdom.
He trusted those things the first two times here,
David trusted God, including at the end,
by trusting and and trusting God by listening to
and obeying this prophet, something
that Saul had never done.
That was the contrast, right?
Saul and David handling differently. The ways of God.
Here he hears from the prophet, he says,
okay, I'm going.
And so we saw that sin brings consequences.
But similarly, when David trusted the Lord here,
it brought about powerful deliverances in his life.
Sin brings consequences.
But trusting the Lord brings about powerful deliverances.
We already see it start here.
You remember in the first two verses of chapter 22,
there's all these, these ragtag group
of warriors showing up around David.
400 men who were disenfranchised with Saul.
They believed God over anything else. All these things.
They see David as the king and they wanted to be with him.
Those 400 end up being the mighty men of valor Later
that David sees God do amazing things
to free his people and to redeem his people
and to defeat enemies.
God starts the deliverance process even here.
But, but notice even like consequences
of sin can often be delayed.
Sometimes Deliverances can often be delayed.
They were for David here.
'cause David doesn't get back into the kingship,
doesn't get back into Jerusalem immediately.
He's on the run for months.
Even though God says, I got you,
here's the deliverance I'm bringing months later
is when it actually showed up.
But, but see it here.
Every time David placed his trust in the Lord
with Goliath, with Saul here, every time
God came through in deliverance, God was
showing up just the right time.
God was blessing that it was all
because he trusted God when he took it into his own hands.
Consequences when he trusted God deliverance.
So see, this suffering was the training camp
that God used in David's life to prepare David
to be the humble dependent king
that God wanted him to be.
He didn't want him to end up like Saul.
So he took him through all of these things
to watch him grow into the man of God.
He was, it was hard,
but it was necessary for David
to be the greatest king of Israel.
See, there's so many parallels between
what David was experiencing to what we experienced today.
I mean, just think about where David was in this process.
He was not home yet. He was in exile.
He was on the run from an enemy
and he was living around people
who did not share the same beliefs about God that he did.
Does that not sound familiar?
Does that not sound like what you and I face every day?
Scripture is clear that Jesus's kingdom is not
of this world.
So if we are in him,
then this world is not our home.
Philippians three 20, our citizenship is in heaven.
So, so think about that.
That means we are foreigners in a hostile land just like
David was, right?
David's on the run, he's not home, he's not secure.
He's in all these other countries.
He's running through the desert.
He's a foreigner in a hostile land.
We are too Christian.
We are foreigners in a hostile land.
Now again, most of us don't have Saul trying to kill us,
but we are just as much aliens and strangers here.
We're not home yet. We're on the run from an enemy
and we live around people
who don't share the same beliefs about God as we do,
in fact are often hostile to us.
So what should we do? How do we respond to that?
Lemme give you a couple ideas.
First, we must stop denying the reality
of the danger we are in.
Stop denying the reality of the danger.
See, David could not be in denial about
his situation, right?
He had to acknowledge it.
In fact, he did very clearly in Psalm 34
and Psalm 56, which we believe based on the heading
of those two, that David wrote those in the
midst of this trial.
In chapter 21, he's on the run, he's living in caves.
He's trying to run away from Saul.
And he writes Psalm 34
and Psalm 56, I would encourage you to go find those later.
Go read through them completely.
Now that you have the picture of the story,
how he was feeling and how he responded.
Lemme give you an example. This is Psalm 56
verses one and two.
David says, be gracious to me.
Oh God, for man tramples on me all day long.
An attacker oppresses me.
My enemies trample on me all day long
for many attack me proudly.
Like David was not in denial about the danger he was in.
It cannot be any different for us
like it does us no good to stick our head in the sand
and claim that everything's fine.
Like it's all good. No problems, right?
Just denying reality. The reality is if we are living
to advance the gospel, trouble will come.
It might be variable depending on the cultural environment
in which we live, right?
Some places, sometimes it'll be harder or easier dependent.
Yes, but Jesus himself said it,
John 1633, in the world, you will have trouble.
Not you might, you will.
But remember those hardships, the trouble
are the training camp that God will use
to prove your faith, to grow your dependence on him.
If we see it that way, like we,
we could see it as just punishment and hardship
or we could see it as God using it to refine us.
Yet here's, here's something we don't need to do.
At the same time, yes, trouble will come,
but we don't need to do anything to increase the danger
by our own foolishness.
We must avoid increasing the danger in
the world that we face.
Foolishly,
maybe you can relate to this.
I've certainly done it myself.
I will blame the world
or blame the enemy for something that I brought on myself.
Anyone ever done that before?
Like you, you know what I mean by that?
Here's, here's what I mean. I'll make a foolish decision
or I will sin.
And instead of taking ownership for the day, the difficulty
that it brings in my life, I'll point the finger at Satan.
I'll point the finger at the world.
Like, man, the devil's really coming after me right now.
Like both spiritual warfare is really strong.
No, I was just a fool and I'm paying for it, right?
Like don't, don't shift the blame.
And so how does that apply here?
Well, well again, some would argue
that David's in wartime mentality right here.
And so some things are not as black
and white like think of, you know, lying
to protect the Jews in the Nazi Germany area.
Like, okay, there's some things
that maybe it's gray, alright?
But the reality is that most of us are not in
nor ever will be in a situation like that.
Most of us, most of our lives simply
increase the danger we face through our own foolishness.
Like we poke and prod on social media
and we wonder why we get a rise outta people.
We refuse to listen to wise counsel soul.
Instead, we go our own way and we get in all kinds of messes
or we arrogantly stride into temptation
thinking we're stronger than we really are.
We neglect time in God's word in prayer with brothers
and sisters in the church.
And then we wonder why we miss the fact
that the enemy is duping us every day.
See, there will be risk
and danger in following Jesus,
even when we're doing it righteously.
Let's not add to it by our own foolishness,
which David seemed to do here a little bit at least.
But then the follow up question is, what happens if we do?
What happens if we do blow it?
We do increase danger foolishly.
We do some stuff that's gonna get us in trouble.
Well, despite our failures, remember
that God's mercies are new every morning.
We have to remember this, that
for sinners like us,
God's mercies are new every morning.
Again, remember David, he had tried to escape danger
through his own efforts instead
of trusting in God.
So what did he need to do? He needed to repent.
He needed to turn away from that and turn back to God.
Well, graciously he knew what Lamentations
three verses 22 and 23 would say.
The steadfast love of the Lord never ceases.
His mercies never come to an end.
They are new every morning.
Great is your faithfulness.
And you know how we knew He knew that?
Because later in his life
after the biggest sin he would ever commit,
he wrote Psalm 51, which is
the preeminent example of what it means to turn back to God
after you blow it.
And this is what it says, have mercy on me.
Oh God, according to your steadfast love.
Does that not sound like Lamentations three, according
to your abundant mercy, blot out my transgressions.
Wash me. I shall be wider than snow.
Create in me a clean heart. Renew a right spirit within me.
Do you see the forgiving mercy there?
And remember, this is pre Christ.
This is long before they knew the mercy of God.
Like we can know the mercy of God.
Just listen to Titus chapter three.
Describe it when the goodness
and loving kindness of God our savior appeared.
He saved us not
because of works done by us in righteousness,
but according to his own mercy, by the washing
of regeneration and renewal of the Holy Spirit.
That's who God is. Church, right?
That's who we need to remember.
We are looking to, when you blow it, when you walk
by the flesh instead of by his spirit, there is mercy there.
Does that mean you take advantage of it?
Take it for granted? No.
It means you should be so overwhelmed by it
that you can't help but say, man, I deserve death.
I get new life. Instead, what am I gonna do?
But give my life to you? And you get that
all because you trust in Jesus's death
and resurrection in your place.
That's mercy. That's that's mercy
that David began to understand more
and more about as he drew nearer to his God.
And listen, this is a journey
David had to grow.
He didn't have it all figured out at the beginning.
He was a man after God's own heart
and still blew it a couple times and many times
and different ways as we journey home.
'cause we're not home yet. As we journey home in the midst
of this hostile land, as we stumble our way
through all of this, what's the sustaining hope?
It's mercy. But there's also something at the end,
something we can lean on.
Here's what it is. We can trust
that God's redemption is coming.
We can trust that God's redemption is coming.
And it appears that that's what David did
towards the end of this training camp.
It seems like he finally got it.
He, he finally grasped this idea that,
that I need to trust the Lord.
I need to listen to God through his prophet.
I need to do this. I can't trust myself. I got to trust him.
And he might have been the whole time, we don't know that.
We can't see in behind the scenes,
but what we know here, sure seems like he grew into that
and, and it's gonna happen to us too.
Maybe God will give you crafty ways
to get outta the enemy's attacks.
I don't know. Okay, that's fine.
But it sure seems like David finally put his life in God's
hands in chapter 22.
You see it in verse three.
He said, till I know what God will do for me,
he, he was waiting on God till I know
what God's gonna do for me.
Even the prophet, did you see that?
The prophet, when he said, Hey David, you need
to go back to Judah.
He was sending him back towards Saul.
And what did David do? Like, no, I can't go back.
I can't do, no, he went.
He went willingly because he trusted God.
Think about even this army, this 400 men
that were gathering around David, they could have tried
a counter attack to go take out Saul first, right?
That's what a, an army would typically do, right?
In a battle. You're like, well if they're coming
after our leader, let's go get their leader.
And these were skilled warriors.
They could have done it, but David didn't.
And really the entire rest of the book, he has opportunities
to take out Saul and he doesn't do it.
'cause he knew that was wrong. He knew that was not
what God wanted from him.
He chose to trust God.
Instead, he trusted God with Goliath.
Couldn't he trust God with Saul?
And we see this again in Psalm 34
and Psalm 56.
Go read these later. But this is David in the middle.
Watch this Psalm 34, verses six and seven.
He says, this poor man cried and the Lord heard him
and saved him out of all his troubles.
The angel of the Lord Enc camps around those
who fear him and delivers them.
Psalm 34 17, when the righteous cry for help, the Lord hears
and delivers them out of all their troubles,
34 19, many are the afflictions of the righteous,
but the Lord delivers him out of them all 34 22.
The Lord redeems the life of his servants.
None of those who take refuge in him will be condemned.
And then this is Psalm 56 verses three
and four, he says, David says, when I am afraid,
I put my trust in you.
In God whose word I praise in God, I trust
I shall not be afraid.
What can flesh do to me?
Like is that not an amazing statement?
Jesus said something similar later,
but David says, notice in the middle
of the hardships in the training camp,
as Saul isn't trying to kill him,
David says, what can flesh do to me?
What can that guy, what can that guy do to me?
Notice David had learned
to trust his God, his deliver.
Can we not do the same?
Can we not see the training camp that he's putting you
through right now is his means to get you to trust him more.
To trust that God will resolve all the mess that's
around us, to trust not
ourselves, but trust that God will redeem us
and will take us home one day.
That we don't have to use cunning and all of our wisdom
and all of our skills and all of our resources
to try to fix it all.
No. 'cause remember this,
our ultimate hope is not in figuring out how to get all
of this back to a comfortable, secure, peaceful state.
It's just not. That can't be our hope.
Our hope is only in the fact
that God will redeem all of this.
He will bring restoration someday.
But how do we consider this rightly?
Well, always we read the text, we read the scripture,
we see the world through the lenses of Jesus Christ.
And so as we consider this idea
of trusting God in the training camp, looking
to his restoration, our minds should go to
how Jesus trusted his father.
So think about this. Jesus willingly
submitted to his father's plan, which by the way
included his suffering
because he knew of the redemption
that was going to be brought on the other side.
He was the ultimate
foreigner in a hostile land.
Yet his purpose was to live, die, and resurrect so that you
and I could have a hope and a future.
Plus, he never stretched the truth.
He never acted foolishly.
Yet he took our severe
consequences to give us powerful deliverance.
And so see what's happening here, right?
David was a fallen, imperfect hero.
But Christ is the perfect David.
Our champion is the one who's going to bring us hope forever
and ever and ever.
Like. So David's limited picture,
fallen picture is pointing us to the greater David, to Jesus
who was fully dependent on his Father in all the ways
that David failed in all the ways that you and I fail.
And so the question again, how are we gonna respond
to the training camp that we're in related?
How dependent on him are you
like just at ground level?
Do you really depend on him?
Do you really depend on him? Often? Here's the reality.
I so often I need
to stop trusting my own strength
and start trusting the Lord to deliver me, to empower me
to work through me.
Is that true for you two?
Do you need to trust him more?
Do you need to depend on him more
so that he flows through you?
Okay, so the question is, what do you do with that today?
How do you do that today?
What do you need to do today to get there?
How can you become more dependent on the indwelling one,
the spirit we sang about earlier?
How can you be more filled with him?
Who gives you the power that you need to live this life?
Because we are foreigners in a hostile land
and this training camp is far too difficult for us
to make it through on our own.
And so what do you do with that? You lean on Christ,
you lean on him, and you trust
that his redemption is coming someday.
And you can have all of that hope to help you make it
through the hard days that are here.
That's what he does.